so we got a new little exclusive here oh
yeah
a little dayton hypernova was sent to me
okay i know dayton new dayton video
only has eight views because he only
posts them on his facebook page
uh what's going on with dayton and his
family
i'm getting on camera right now that my
older brother escape is shouting crazy
at my
dad who's turning 80 years old in less
than a week downstairs
but we've seen you yell at your dad yeah
it's for ordering the pizza from the
wrong place
and not getting your health burritos
yeah and not just giving you a credit
card for no reason yeah
[Laughter]
or yelling at him because you stole his
credit card and wouldn't pay him back
the money so you could buy more dresses
on
amazon there's these are downstairs
shouting right now
this beats me in front of that
you know what i would love to is if he
gets closer if the mic was able to pick
it up and all you hear is go is is them
going
you're full of [ __ ] the bengals are not
going all the way this year
no you're an idiot dude come on you
really think the bengals are gonna go
all the way and you just go
oh so they're having a friendly they're
having a thing that two guys do over
football
preaching something about preaching
[Music]
not as bad as dayton but he's still he's
still piece of [ __ ] yeah the brother's
bad but how does
how is that dad still alive like that
weak
shouting he has to do all the time like
i'm surprised his heart hasn't just
given out on him
[Music]
how i'm the person that listens
i'm the person that supports i'm the
person to care for people
i'm the person who wants him when
there's trouble
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
she's
my older brother is literally
sarcastically laughing at my phone
right now
we've seen you be a dick to your father
we've seen you yell at your father also
dayton
here we go the big reveal
that skinhead who's shouting like crazy
down there
as an old man our father i mean the
skinhead's been living in the house for
slightly more than seven years
what rice
what's what let him be a hypocrite but
isn't that what he does
yes but it's different because he has
really bad skin problems
and is a
and we're in the middle of the paper now
so it's really hard to just get proper
floating for myself
it's idiotic of him because in seven
years he's never had a job
he refuses to work and he beats me in
front of these people and he's over
twice my songs
moved home from los angeles seven years
ago
where he was trying to be a boxer in
training i don't think he ever
once won a fight out there at least he's
tried to be something
yeah i mean he left and went and tried
and failed
there or any kind of boxing match
men are too intimidating for him so he
beats
half the size well the men these are
also men
that's terrible and it's starting to be
cold and that's right he's not
he's true but he's a lesbian so he likes
women
don't forget they're all [ __ ] in
september and
i'm like in like what several
layers of hoodies to stay warm i have
rhythmic psoriasis all over my body
it's a genetic condition that
neither of them have
it's everywhere on my body dude
it's it's it's this uh we know dayton we
know
i mean and this this is my issue it's
like he's obviously got issues that
i i would be inclined to be a little
sympathetic about it
but there are people with far worse
issues of course
that are thriving in life thriving
there's people that have there are guys
that went to iraq
and lost three out of four of their
limbs
and they're driving cars going grocery
shopping
playing golf and you're like you know
what i mean like i'm sorry man
you get to a point where it's like i
want to feel bad for
people man but sometimes people just i
don't know what happened to
to dayton here to earp well you need
some johnny apple cbd probably help that
out
you know i think johnny apple's cbd and
again this is not
this is just my opinion is a freebie
just my opinion
okay johnny apple makes no statements
uh nobody's making any but it's my
opinion
that if he did johnny apple's cbd he
would be
completely functioning normal person
within a week wow
that's just my opinion wow i have no
scientific evidence to pass that's
amazing and if you used promo code rotc
20 office whole order that's crazy
years to be able to save up enough and
be able to invest in anything to be able
to take care of myself really reliable
but you have what is what i don't
understand
earl right like i've had times in my
life where i was down on my luck
hard to find work all that kind of stuff
right
what what are you doing though like what
are you doing about it like i get i get
where to put
now because this is a problem too with
now a lot of people who are just bums
anyway
they all have that built-in excuse yeah
that's cool
man it's rough out here but we've
watched you for a year now
more over a year in a booming economy
you sat around and did nothing so what
do you
what do you think how does he think this
works
did you just hang out in the house all
day and someday you have enough money to
get like
that's not how it works john the fourth
goes on anakin lost three out of four
limbs and went on to
to a successful career middle management
he was a [ __ ] general
there you go you know what i mean come
on get your act together but
it's so fashionable and like basically
i just have to sit in this house all day
and i can't figure out why i'm not rich
there's a major international
going on global see what i mean bombs
love that excuse now economic
trouble so why you haven't windexed your
[ __ ] mirror
there's this guy that uh is a great
example of it
uh student lance that a bunch of people
used to know from tampa
lance used to be a dj and he honestly he
was just a he was
he was a dude who was cool at one point
but was an absolute prick to everybody
and now he's just a junkie like he's
just a heroin addict
and he's been dming everybody
on facebook every single person and
every person with
mutual friends asking for money because
he's like i'm homeless and i lost my job
because of the
and i just need to get a roof over my
head he shows people pictures of his kid
then they send him money and then what
he does is he'll take like 20 bucks from
people
and then he blocks them on all platforms
yeah you told me about this
yeah and then he just goes and does
heroin he's doing the same thing and
i've seen a lot more people doing this
like
hey man uh anybody got any like work out
there dude
it's rough but if you go back and look
at his facebook
he was fired back in january for being a
[ __ ] degenerate who couldn't get to
work on time
so he's doing like these people that are
now doing the whole oh it's a global
that's why i'm down on my luck and it's
like yeah but your life sucked for two
years leading up to the
what are you talking about the camera
because
they were shouting like crazy at each
other because they're completely
unstable they
are the kind of people that refuse to
seek counseling in their lives
and i have to go see a counselor as soon
as i'm about it you're just
a deal as soon as you move as soon as he
moves out any day
drain on me from all of the abuse
physical and verbal and psychological
abuse from these people on a daily basis
when he was going on before my skinhead
brother moved home
i mean it was before that and there and
both my parents are
psychologically abusive towards each
other
towards me i'm trying they have a
religious belief against that because
okay but then so leads [ __ ] too and
here's the thing look if
all you were was
i think your parents wouldn't like that
about you
but they'd still be okay with you i
really see that like
i i know i know people you know
personally
that you know their parents are very
religious they come out as
and their parents don't like it of
course you know because they're
religious and i get that but
but outside of being that they have a
job they're
good they're good you know whatever and
the parents kind of go like oh i don't
like that aspect of your life and
maybe that's not talking about at a
dinner table but
they they would they would deal with
it you know their problem with you early
they've never yelled at you about being
at least never video that we've ever
seen they they yell at you about they
pay you a hundred dollars to do laundry
and you don't do it
you take their credit card to buy
dresses to start a boutique shop
and his boutique shop is going to be
remember the clothes is going to be free
and people could donate
i think that was his business plan the
the the lgbt community in dayton
despises him and that's not me saying
anything wrong that's
we've talked about it like the the the
this lgbt group in dayton doesn't want
him
around like they don't like him either
and i don't think they don't accept you
because you
dating i think they don't accept you
because you're pain in the ass dude
yeah and it's you're exhausting and
people don't like that